now that we've described the
displacement of our object remember that
our displacement vector Delta R in this
time interval was X of t plus t minus X
of T I hat which we denoted as Delta X I
hat now let's just remind ourselves that
this distance here that's Delta X and
this whole distance from here over to
there that's what we mean by X of T plus
delta T and now what we'd like to do is
describe what we call average velocity
and our average velocity depends on our
time interval so this is for a time
interval T to T plus delta T well the
person has displaced a certain amount of
vector Delta R and our definition for V
average it's a vector quantity so we'll
write the average we'll use three bars
to indicate a definition it is the
displacement during a time interval
delta T so as a vector we have Delta x
over delta T I hat and this component
here is what we call the component of
the average velocity so this is the
component of the average velocity
and again is before this component can
be positive zero or negative depending
on the sign of Delta X and the key point
here is that average velocity depends on
whatever time interval you're referring
to so that's our definition of average
velocity and now what we want to do is
consider what happens in the limit as
delta T becomes smaller and smaller and
smaller and that will enable us to
introduce our concept of instantaneous
velocity